mein name ist mayotte roman wie zu hause
in sankt michael megawatt an hochzeiten
da kann man dank der präsidentin einheit
und hier heraus salzburg
der kommandant der assistenz kompanie
für das miteinander salzburg wenn ihr
heraus mit 120 soldaten eingesetzt an
der deutsch österreichischen grenze
wir unterstützen die polizei weil den
kontrollen an den grenzen trägt
es ist mir bewusst dass das für alle
einfordern da einsatz ist und das in
allen bereichen opfer zu bringen soll
vor allem bei den familien zu hause bei
den frauen und bei den kindern wollen
wir jetzt zur zeit nicht anwesend sein
können und unterstützen aber dafür sagen
wir soldaten
ich bin da einfach nur um verständnis
und dass man in dieser besonderen
situation alle zusammen halten die
soldaten mit ihren familien gemeinsam
als österreicher und österreicherinnen
werden das natürlich schaffen
bleiben sie gesund zu hause und einen
schönen gruß aus salzburg dankeschön